une crise peut en cacher une autre il y
a quelques jours dans le camp de viale
sur l'île de chios une réfugiée
irakienne de 47 ans est décédé à
l'hôpital après une forte fièvre
si la piste du coronavirus a été écartée
par les autorités cette version est
vivement contesté par les migrants dans
le camp un incendie a été déclenchée en
signe de protestation
avec d'importants dégâts à la clé si
l'ordre est revenu après l'arrestation
de trois personnes
l'absence de protection et la difficulté
d'accès aux soins exacerbe la crainte
d'être contaminé par le coronavirus de
l'autre côté de la mer egée accra lydie
l'inquiétude grandit aussi dans un hôtel
transformé en refuge 148 demandeurs
d'asile ont été testés positifs au
qu'ovide 19 de membres du personnel de
l'établissement ont aussi été
contaminées sont anxieux en colère c'est
logique et sans panique avec plus
d'enfants mais tout ira bien
l'ours à dieu nous sommes tous en bonne
santé et j'espère que le virus est
contenue dans le camp évidemment que
nous le sentons concernés
c'est un phénomène sans précédent sont
cette région mais aussi pour toute la
grèce nous sommes dit inquiet mais si
les deux les forces ont bien coordonnées
nous pourrons faire face à la situation
si aucun ne présente de symptômes la
zone a été mise en quarantaine et un
couvre-feu a été instauré dans la ville
l'auberge de crédit est le troisième
camp de migrants du pays à être touchés
par le virus
le ministre grec de l'immigration a
décidé de prolonger jusqu'au 10 mai le
confinement imposé à tous les comptes du
pays